good evening everybody thanks for making
it out on a cold day hopefully everybody
staying warm
so I'm Sean and one of the co-organizers
of patio and harbor this little stuff
ends England was in the back there rose
putler our usual host is not here today
but as she's one of our core organizers
as well I'd like to acknowledge some of
our sponsors so I would like to thank
num focus for sponsoring this Meetup TD
Ameritrade which is my employer here for
sponsoring this meetup space and also to
Midas at the University of Michigan for
sponsoring the delicious food that
you're consuming so if you see any one
of those these people across time please
do thank them a couple important points
emergency exits in case of emergency
there's an exit right here and there's a
staircase right outside the doors that
you came in through provide feedback at
any time together any one of the
co-organizers you can also tweet at us
at Pineta Ann Arbor or you can send us
an email at pie data and Arbor at
gmail.com and just remember that we're
in a borrowed space so please do clean
up after yourselves
there are garbage cans right we're right
next to where the food is also for Q&A
so unless it's a quick question please
hold it until the end
also please try to phrase your question
in the form of a question and try to
keep the questions to 30 seconds or less
and avoid long statements or monologues
there will be time for open questions at
the end and also time for you to even
come up and engage with our speaker as
well oh I'd like to read up on you
Dakota conduct
so Pineta is dedicated to providing a
harassment free meeting experience for
everyone regardless of gender sexual
orientation gender identity and
expression disability physical
appearance body size race religion or
experience we do not tolerate harassment
of meeting participants in any form all
communication should be appropriate for
a professional audience including people
of many different backgrounds and levels
of experience sexual language and
imagery is not appropriate for any of
our meet of events be kind to others do
not insult or put-down other attendees
behave professionally remember that
harassment and sexist racist or
exclusionary jokes are not appropriate
for high data
attendees violating these rules may be
asked to leave the meetup at the sole
discretion of the meetup organizers but
overall thank you for making this a
welcoming
environment for everybody a quick
icebreaker since I see a lot of new
faces is thanks to the our speaker for
recommending this is turn to somebody
there on your left or the right that
you've met that you've not met before or
in front of your behind you introduce
yourselves and tell them what you'd like
to do what activity like to do in the
wintertime when there's snow on the
ground we'll take a maybe two minutes to
quickly introduce yourself and sit in
tell him so hopefully everybody has met
somebody new this time a couple of
things this month in data science there
is a PI data Los Angeles conference
coming up December 3 to 5 as well as PI
data Austin which is happening in
December 7 to 8 I think these are the
remaining us PI data conferences that
are happening this year but do check out
the patio website as well at pioneer.org
for other future events I was just at
one we would just have one last week in
New York another thing too is I know
that there's a lot of people that that
ask us how you might be able to support
the hydrated community so right now I
guess from November 11th to 28th is PI
giving so if you're if you feel so
inclined in our feeling generous please
do support and donate money to the PI
data organization or non focused
organization this will help fund a lot
of not only our local meetup as well as
many media's across the world and you
can go to an unfocused org slash donate
to pi giving and also next month speaker
is a list elizabeth wicks and she'll we
talk about what happens when your data
aren't numbers so in the case of very
messy dirty data where you have to clean
it up there aren't numbers so come out
for that that's on December 4th also
Wednesday I wanted to open it up for any
community announcements that anybody
might have whether you are you have job
postings where you're looking for a job
feel free to raise your hand and tell us
your name
yes I worked at clean right here in Ann
Arbor all conversation on mana we are
partying a hydrator so they're
interested in training other people to
build conversationally applications
I'll talk to me afterwards great other
folks yes I'm fairly close I'm just for
a winder for anyone who needs one I'm
tomorrow on my this is doing on their
Emmanuel symposium it's a rack and Hall
just a couple blocks from here and I um
I went once before like it was a lot of
fun a lot a really interesting talks and
if anyone has time to do that tomorrow
not welcome here we go
that's the next two days I think right
yeah yeah there's a positive side
anybody else
okay great with that I'd like to
introduce our speaker so we have Rachel
my shake who is coming from New York
City to visit us today Rita has a
statistics statistics background but she
also has skills in Python are in sass
she is an organizer at meetup group so
the New York City women and machine
learning and data science and also the
New York City PI ladies group recently
she was also co organizing or organizing
the psyche learn sprints in the Bay Area
and so let's welcome
Irish man as our speaker today okay yeah
so to introduce myself again my name is
rhea sh my shake and my talk today is
about community building calling it the
good and the messy part of it as as sean
introduced me I'm an independent
statistician and data scientist
I started off after finishing college my
first job was that Educational Testing
Service that's the company that designs
all these SATs and all that I worked on
the SAT Subject Tests and after that I
got into the pharmaceutical industry and
I worked there for over 10 years on
clinical trials and during that time I
went to I started my MBA and that's
where I was introduced to data science
back in 2012 it was called the first
course I took was data mining which is
now called data science I've been
organizing for the New York Chapter of
women machine learning data science for
five years now it was a second chapter
of women and machine learning data
science and I've been organized for PI
ladies for two years I'm also a board
member for big apple pie and that is the
organization that puts on the annual PI
coffin conference in New York City and I
recently became a board member of women
in analytics which has a great
conference over in Ohio which I hear is
a rival rival football city too so I
won't so but it's it's a great
conference all right I want to you know
I want to say
as an organizer I know you know how much
time goes into organizing these events
and arranging for me to come here and I
really want to thank everybody who has
contributed to this PI data and um focus
TD Ameritrade Shawn for inviting me and
Michigan data science institute for
forum food I also I just want to say you
know how short and I connected Shawn I
was on the data frame podcast and so is
Shawn and we ended up stalking on
Twitter and that's how we became
connected so thank you for listening to
my podcast and you know for organizing
and inviting me over and also thanks to
everybody for coming out here especially
since I know you just recently had snow
much earlier than you expected
so the theme of this talk is going to be
about
come on community diversity inclusion
accessibility open source and this is
going to be like the broad strokes of
this conversation I'm gonna begin with
the gender imbalance in tech it's pretty
it's pretty skewed as you may have heard
and so I put together this data for a I
did a presentation earlier this year for
a major financial company in New York
because I was trying to get sponsorship
for these open source Sprint's that I
was organizing and so I went in and I
picked some key information and you can
see you know I heard tech to law school
in med school and we can see like where
that drop is intact this data is for the
United States only partly because that's
where I could find data for and I used
the most recent available statistics for
each category so for instance you know
med school law school had recent
publications for 2017 and wherever I
could find the data but you know even if
the data was a few years old it's
actually quite consistent because there
were categories where I could find data
for three years
and there wasn't you know a big jump I
was not successful in getting
sponsorship before that for that sprint
and so I was like what can I do next
time and so they say a picture is worth
a thousand words and so I put together a
visualization the first visualization I
put together just I just had a rough one
I put it on Twitter and it really it
really resonated with people and I
received some feedback for it and I made
it into a different kind of visual and
visualization here and you know we can
see here you know like med school in law
school actually it's almost it's 50%
more women or enrolled and these are
graduate programs and you can see the
steep decline once it hits tack machine
learning and then all the subsets after
that whether it's open source
contributions open source contributions
to our or Python which are both major
data science languages and finally to
scikit-learn it you know it's very low
so create this visualization so some of
the topics that I'm going to cover in
this summary which are related to
diversity in tech are the discover
cookbook which is a project Bynum focus
that I worked on
I was so non focus actually I'll get
into the code of conduct workshops deep
learning spirit notes anybody here have
done the fast day I deep learning course
online yeah okay great because I
actually put together some notes for it
I don't know you may have may or may not
have seen own and open-source prints
I'll talk about them and then the to
meetup groups that that we'd mentioned
previously okay
and so for each of these points I'm sort
of gonna touch on you know what it is
why it's relevant you know some some
links to the resources if you want to
look at them I can make these slides
available if you know if you want to
research this further or further or get
involved further there are suggestions
on how to do that and you know where
applicable this is where the title the
talk comes from the good and the messy
is some of the challenges where
applicable
so the discover cookbook the discover
cookbook is a project Bynum focus so num
focus started this committee called disk
which is called diversity and scientific
computing to increase diversity and it
began in the spring of 2017 so it's
about two and a half years old and so I
was on the committee for two years my
term ended in the spring of 2019 and
during that time I worked on a few
projects and one of the projects I
worked on was this discovery cookbook
and in the in November of 2019 so about
two years ago we had a dis con
conference which I was also involved in
and so we brought new people to become
involved and so new people have taken
over the project and the current
contributors are Leone milk MIDI condena
Rubalcaba and I believe MIDI can
actually spoke here right so for those
of you were here for that talk she is
now working on that the goal of this
discover cookbook is we know that you
know diversity we can improve diversity
and it's a resource for event organizers
whether it's meetups or conferences to
make them more diverse and inclusive
okay and so some of the examples of the
practices and the suggestions that are
in this cookbook and the link it was on
the previous slide if you want to
explore it more fully is getting
diversity in speakers at conferences and
talks and also not just speakers but
people who are on the organizing
committee for these events at the code
of conduct I have to say I got some
goosebumps when Sean who was reading the
code of conduct because I was actually
on the committee that worked on that and
I learned a lot from from that whole
experience and I've definitely brought
what I've learned to my meetup groups
just some other examples that make
events more inclusive and accessible to
people or having nursing rooms for
mothers and childcare and also like
access to refrigerator to store milk
dietary restrictions which you know I
see we're doing here
access sign language interpreters
photography pronouns
other examples are I noticed that you
know on Twitter somebody had posted
something about how it was difficult for
him to see presentations because of
color blindness so making that
accessible and also just you know other
things for instance if people are
wearing really strong perfumes or
colognes it can it can trigger asthma so
you know there's there's a lot these
practices to make events more accessible
and inclusive they span a wide range of
options so there's a lot of options and
they're broken down into high impact low
effort and high impact high effort or
things you know and something that's
really like easy to do for instance is
pronouns not all the recommendations and
this in this you know in this cookbook
are required but they're suggestions and
the goal is really implement as much as
as possible you know some things that
could be a bit more I can have a strong
impact or gender-neutral bathrooms and
nursing rooms and something that's for
instance high impact high effort is
something like child making childcare
available it's an extra it's an extra
cost but it can also bring more people
to in events and again you know not all
the suggestions there are required by
any means but there are some options and
something to consider over time to sort
of move to that area so there are ways I
wanted to make this actionable so people
could sort of see what what we do what
we've done and what options are
available and how much you know you want
to be aware so beginning it's just just
being aware that this is available is
very helpful the other thing to do is to
reference it and this could also be like
a an event at work or you know this is
sort of focused on data science but
really whatever if you're involved in a
community group whether it's your
homeowners or so
Asian or your co-op or a place of
worship or any any community groups that
you're involved in a lot of these things
that I'm going to discuss here are
actually applicable to all of that it's
it's not really restricted to the data
science community so you know to share
it with everybody there are ways to
contribute to the cookbook it's a github
repository so the usual whatever with
github repositories you can open an
issue can you give feedback you can star
the repo just to bring more traffic to
it you can also submit a PR if you have
a suggestion to it so in addition to
that num focus for the disc committee
there is a mailing list and so you can
keep sort of just up to speed on what
they're what they're up to and what
progress they're making on their
projects and so the disc committee is a
subcommittee of num focus was so you can
also sign it for the non focus
newsletter so I was a dis committee
member for two years and I wrote a blog
about the projects that I worked on and
so if at any point you want to become
involved in the disc committee they have
steering committee members like chair
chair of committees and then also
committee members and there are
different ways to be involved so there's
more information on my blog here the
code of conduct so a great example is
num focuses code of conduct which I
learned a lot from the great thing about
having codes of conduct at any events is
that they they promote professionalism
and civility and thus you know very
welcoming space and so there's you know
there's a short version and then there's
a really long version so people can read
the shorter version and there's also
information there about the reporting
procedure and so how people can
participate it participate in it is the
first thing that I say for anything is
just being aware that it exists that's
always very helpful and so you know
there was a time when I would as a
meet-up work on our I would
promote conferences from other other
organizations and I realized that many
of the conference's I was promoting
actually didn't have a code of conduct
and I thought oh well I'm actually on a
committee for code of conduct and I'm
promoting conferences that don't have it
so now the first thing that I do before
I sign up for a conference or I promote
it is I see do they have a code of
conduct or do they not if they don't I
say you know if you don't have one
here's one that you can recommend using
and they can just give attribution to
non focus I personally prefer educating
people over a boycotting an event so
instead of saying I'm not going to go to
your conference because you don't have a
code of conduct I can say you know I
really think that this is going to be
helpful it's going to be more welcoming
and here's something that you can do to
make it happen and it's actually worked
I've actually I've reached out to three
different conferences and they have
implemented the code of conduct so
that's still evolved and finally in
addition to you know of course all of us
following the codes of conduct is
reporting the violations if you see
something you know say something we can
all contribute to making events more
welcoming so you know I actually wrote a
blog about codes of conduct and they're
great right but they're not a panacea
they don't solve all the problems and
this is these are some of the reasons
why it doesn't solve everything if
sometimes there is when I run events for
my meetup group in New York I will at
times I have this like call it a delayed
reaction so something happens at my
meetup group and I don't really process
it in my head until I go home that night
I go to bed I don't sleep I don't follow
safe and I'm like oh something's
bothering you and then I kind of think
back about what happened so so you know
an example is that for instance I had
one event where I had to tell multiple
times so two women just you know -
please stop speaking because other
people are competing that they're being
disruptive and then this woman was a bit
inebriated and I you know I kind of felt
uncomfortable but I didn't actually say
anything and it
took a while for my for me to process
that so while we have codes of conduct
and we have you know sort of methods on
dealing with it sometimes we don't like
I don't recognize that there's a problem
until later on there's also a gray area
where sometimes someone does something
it's not specifically spelled out in the
Code of Conduct but it can be disruptive
to people or make them uncomfortable so
you know for this particular event I had
emailed the woman and I you know I gave
her my feedback and she she apologized
and so you know and asked you know I'm
sorry can I can I stay in the group and
the thing is when I post an events on
meetup we have the code of conduct
stated when we send a reminder email we
have the code of conduct as a reminder
at the beginning of our event we also
talked about the code of conduct so when
somebody asks for oh can you just give
me a warning it's I it's understandable
and I think warnings are important but
it's also like it disrupted the event
and if every time there is one little
thing that happens at an event it can be
disruptive there's always some
disruption at an event and I understand
you know people want warnings but it can
also be problematic so there's the other
thing about reporting violations and
managing violations and we talk about it
but there's not a whole lot of
discussion out there and how people
manage there's not a lot of transparent
open discussion on what exactly are some
of these violations and how are people
handling them and how can other people
learn from them and I think that that's
going to be the next step in codes of
Keio it's nice to have a code of conduct
but what what's next you know there's
there's there's codes of conduct 2.0
coming up there is a trainee that
there's some training by a company
called auto technology and I first see
other companies sort of offering this
training on how to deal with situations
related to violations or certain
behaviors at events so the next topic
that I'm going to talk about still in
the same theme or it's open source
get workshops so you know in my opinion
I get is so important to open source
data science accessibility it's it's
what it's what driving is in the suburbs
right if you live in the suburbs and you
don't have a car it's really difficult
to get around and if you're in data
science and you don't really know get
very well it takes longer to clone the
repo each time it takes longer to make
changes it takes it makes contributing
to open source not really possible it
makes you know there's there's the free
github blog hosting that can be used as
a website but not for people who don't
know get it's also for sharing code you
know that's that's accessible for people
who want to share what projects they're
working on to share with the community
but also you know to create a portfolio
for looking for jobs in my experience
it's been it's not something that
traditional University programs have
really prioritized I've been you know
even as just my experience it's like you
should know get but it's a it's
important but it's not so important that
we're gonna teach you and so what what
I've done in New York it actually it
started I had gotten to a meet-up and
somebody asked to me and organized the
meetup asked me this is before I had
done any speaking ever and said when are
you gonna do a talk I don't know and he
said well what are you gonna talk about
I'm like I I don't know why I could talk
about get because at the time I had to
work in a boot camp and I would give
they get lectures and so that is when I
put together a talk for a meetup group
and I gave multiple talks and I I you
know updated the curriculum each time so
that's sort of how the get workshop
started and so I've given over two dozen
free get workshops over the past two
years in New York City and the demand is
there people want to know get probably I
could give a get workshop every month
and have at least two dozen or more
people and they get workshop so my
curriculum is available on github
it's openly available so you're welcome
to use it you're welcome to use it to
give workshops and share with other
people the approaches it's a it's a
bottom-up approach actually got this
idea from fast day I wear you know
Jeremy how it just goes in and teaches
it and says worried about the details
later and so forget I just I go through
all the steps because there are other
tutorials out there with that discuss
things like branches but this sort of
teaches you how to use it and I created
these workflows which are step by steps
so it's each step you know what I do
when I teach it is I go through three
steps and I say okay now you do it then
I usually have try to have one TA for
every five to ten students and we go
through the step and there's different
workflows for creating a repo cloning a
repo pushing changes to it and with
branches and this is an example on what
cloning means and such and so again like
here's something actionable how can you
participate yeah you can use the
curriculum you can tell other people
about it you could give a get workshop
at work or at a meetup group you can
also like contribute to it like submit a
PR I the next workflow that needs to be
added is one for undoing changes so
that's sort of the next step
yeah and so the challenge with the as I
stated before with their grid workshops
is it's they're really they're the
demand is high up there you know and so
if you know get you know feel free to
give get workshops and if you don't feel
free to use feel free to use this
reference the next thing which is a
short is the fast day eye deep learning
oh so I know a couple of people here
raised their hand saying that they'd
done the fast day I deep learning course
so this is out of USF Jeremy Howard has
he teaches this course and he records it
and so it's you know it's streamed and
people really like thousands of people
around the world have taken this deep
learning course and so I created these
notes
and you can see they've in terms of
stars and the traffic it's just that the
notes have been helpful to people and so
this is one other way to contribute to
open source is to share your work on
github and such and so and it's also
like writing blogs too and you know as
I'm sharing the good and the messy of
all of this the challenge with that is
maintenance and also one thing that I
didn't expect when I they were sort of
my notes which I made public I was not
prepared for people opening up github
issues and asking me questions and like
oh ho okay that means now I have to
maintain it too so it's something to
keep in mind when you put something out
there occasionally people submit PRS
which is a lot easier because you can
review it and accept it but with
questions or other things that requires
you know sometimes they can require yeah
pull request pull request on github
which means you can change some code and
submit that code and it gets approved by
the owners and can get um you know can
get incorporated into the current code
base okay so the next thing I'm going to
talk about still nothing we've
open-sourced a scikit-learn spread so
how many people who use scikit-learn
right so most of you know but just in
case you don't scikit-learn is the
machine learning library for python and
this is taken from that visualization
earlier on but the participation rates
by women open-source are really low it's
like 11% you get even lower for python
at 2% and then we go to scikit-learn and
zero to one percent and so as an
organizer for women and machine learning
in data science and also one of the
benefits of living in the city where one
of the co maintainer zuv scikit-learn
also lives is that we can open organize
secular and sprits and what is a spin I
actually didn't know what that word was
when when so when Andre has suggested it
I sort of thought of it as a hackathon
but it's an all-day event which we
typically have on a Saturday to work on
issues on github library and so because
this is for beginners it is we work on
labeled quote easy issues we're not
adding like a massive feature to it
we're making documentation changes small
changes and so the sprint started in
March of 2017 was the first time the
sprint was run and then the next year
the sprint was organized in 2018 and so
the goal of these Sprint's is actually
to get more people involved in
contributing to open source so in 2018
was the first time after the sprint
where I followed up with the
participants who came to the sprint on
the pull request that they submitted
what happened with that was actually
most people didn't respond they didn't
follow up on their work and so for 2019
what I decided to do was I wanted to
because sometimes meetups can be you
know they're very like a low-key sort of
you know just very flexible events but
the Sprint's requires something a little
bit more from the participants and
they're also required to work from the
organizers because it's an all-day event
so I instituted this application process
so people would know first of all to
make sure that people have some level of
Python and scikit-learn knowledge
because if people don't know any Python
they don't really benefit from attending
this friends the second thing is just to
let them know that there's follow-up
work required and hopefully not that
every single person who participates in
the spirit but hopefully if the majority
of them follow up on their work that's
helpful and also to let them know the
process like it can take a month to have
a PR even first think simple document
change merged in there's a lot of back
and forth from the reviewer they suggest
this you try running the tests maybe it
doesn't pass all the tests so there's a
lot of back-and-forth and so it was
instituted for the first time
for the Sprint in Nairobi and I'll get
back to that minute but actually every
PR that was submitted every request that
people worked on at the Nairobi sprint
was completed by the participants which
is really really remarkable and a great
accomplishment I also want to talk a
little bit about Nairobi
so scikit-learn has a history of
Sprint's where in the past it's been
with the contributors very advanced
oftentimes they have them at major
conferences like Syfy and such so the
Sprint's are usually in US and Western
Europe you know and so I decided to
organize a sprint find I Roby because I
looked at the data for women and machine
learning data science and we have a
chapter in Nairobi and it was a fourth
largest chapter with over 2,000 members
and I thought well you know it is we're
having one in New York again the plan
for San Francisco was already in the
works the third largest is Paris which
was already in the works also and I
thought well why not Nairobi you know
and so it's a great story it's oh it's a
long story and I can tell it later if we
have time but flow a contributor from
Berlin to Nairobi and retinas I could
sprint and it was it was great
so I mentioned the reason New York has
had three sprints in a row is because
the co maintainer lives in New York so
we it's it's run by you know one of the
contributors in 2020 one of the main one
of the contributors lives in Berlin and
so the Berlin chapter woman machine
learning data science is also organizing
a sprint
there can be Sprint's outside of where a
contributor lives it's just that it
requires funding for the contributor to
travel there and it hasn't been it
hasn't been entirely easy getting
funding from companies to cover that
travel and to fund the sprints and so
some of the other challenges is so if
the goal is to get long-term
contributors it's going to take a while
to make that tent right when people are
coming in as beginners and building up
that
there is also I mentioned the funding
getting weakened space isn't all so easy
either there are you know very few
companies that have the weakened space
available in New York there is also the
issue of you know if it's if it's summer
or winter the extra heating or air
conditioning there's extra cost
associated because they turn it off on
the weekends it's weather if there are
contributors that are available and
interested in traveling and time and
said you know following up on PRS takes
time it took a lot of my time to do the
2018 and finding finding sort of help
for people to follow them here is it's
important it's important to go through
the whole process it's a great learning
process but it takes time to manage it
and so this is just a photo of the cycle
earn sprint this is a dream here who's a
contributor that lives in Berlin and he
flew down and this is our chapter in
Nairobi and this is just an example of
our website where we have this prints we
have the sprints and so some of their
possibilities for cycle earned you many
of you work for companies is that so in
New York two Sigma's is a financial
company they organize the companies
sprint last year where because they have
developers and this is actually a way to
make a dent in open source with
experienced contributors where they had
20 to 30 developers at the company do a
one-day in-house sprint during the
weekday and to sigmah organize that and
and the we have contributors in New York
who who facilitated that event
another option for scikit-learn is
Columbia University has a cycle learn
lab where developers with machine
learning experience can go and they're
looking for people who can commit to you
know we are faces sprints or one day but
one three or six months so that's an
option and so another another way that
this could look is it in Paris they
often have a developer sprint because I
the scikit-learn library was developed
in Paris so there's a good handful of
core developers that live in Paris and
so they will often have developer
sprints there and they'll invite some
members of community to participate in
the sprint and they can mentor the new
contributors to it and these are links
for the sprint I've also done an impact
report which shows you know how many
peers were submitted how many people
attended what they learned from it what
didn't work well what we could do better
and so a lot of those what could be done
better were implemented in future
sprints and so next I've mentioned women
a machine learning data science so I'm
finally officially going to introduce it
the goal of women and machine learning
data scientists build a welcoming and
supportive community for women and we
are on Twitter and Instagram LinkedIn
our acronym is wim LDS it was founded
six years ago so it's six years old
we now have 80 chapters around the world
in 35 different countries with over
43,000 members it is it's it's just
booming it's been very popular and to
run those community groups there's over
150 organizers and I just you know I'd
like to point out that in a community it
doesn't just include the members it
doesn't just include the organizers but
it also includes you know our sponsors
and people who support us on social
media it really is it's a wide community
that makes it happen and this is the map
for it and you know the great thing
about this is we have a year ago so we
actually doubled in size in a year last
year we had 39 chapters 40 at this time
of the year and now we have exactly
double 78 is we have about seven or
eight chapters in the Middle East a year
a year ago there was just no presence in
the Middle East but we have a chapter in
Casablanca
Algeria it just needs to be the
paperwork needs to be done we have one
in Riyadh Saudi Arabia two in Turkey one
in Cairo one in Israel and also India is
is booming we have a dozen chapters in
India it's just you know these towns
only I was born in India and we receive
requests from cities that I I have to
Google Mike where is this city but it's
been very popular and also we have you
know a really commendable presence in
sub-saharan Africa to so-and-so what we
do is we have speaker events that don't
exclusively feature women but we we
focus on women we have panel discussions
that we require that at least you know
if we're gonna have a panel discussion
at least half of them are women and so
some of the events would that we do is
we give workshops and Python are
tensorflow probability we've done d3
before open source prints career
workshops just coffee networking
sessions and hackathons and you know a
lot of other co promotes with other
meetup groups and a lot of other events
so one of the advantages of being a data
science is I wondered with all of these
meetup groups and all of these events I
said what kind of events do we do and so
I that list first but what I did was I
actually had someone help me she
actually extracted all the titles of
over 500 events that our meetup groups
had organized over the last five years
and so I did an NLP analysis of that and
I calibrated like what number of topics
they picked 10 was a good topic and so
one of them is contribute to open source
which stood out but these are the other
topics so you can see there's Pittsburgh
there's bingo is popular Portland
there's deep learning we see we see
Python show up a lot we don't see our
show up a lot here and that's probably
because the art community has their own
you know they're they're pretty vibrant
community there's a lot of kickoffs for
every time a new chapter started there's
a kickoff event for that tensorflow is
big we see pi torches over there deep
learning has gotten bigger there's some
drinking going on here on Wednesdays and
yeah so it was it was fir it was fun and
it was informative to see what what sort
of events all the chapters were
organizing and so now I'll just talk
about the New York City chapter which is
where I live and where I have organized
for for the past five years we now have
over 4,000 members we've got four active
organizers and we do about one to two
events per month that's our meetup group
it's if you want to follow it we also we
also share a newsletter but we just
share a conferences and information and
resources also so even if you don't live
in New York there's information that's
valuable and available so our culture in
New York City you know there are some
tech groups that women in tech groups
that restrict membership where maybe
they don't really sometimes they
officially restrict it to just women and
non-binary in New York City we've always
welcomed men we you know we wanted to be
inclusive and so some of the challenges
that we have faced in this is that
sometimes even when we have you know 90%
of the attendees are women we find that
like sometimes men do more of the
speaking we've had some challenges where
our events are so popular that we have
the ratio we have a lot we look it's
great that the events are good we have a
lot of men attending and so then because
space is restricted our members complain
well if this is a woman script why can't
I get to the event and so these are just
a challenges that we face as a meetup
group and we know one of the things is
we've started saying let women ask the
questions first and maybe that could
help but there's no there's we haven't
found an easy solution at some
thing that we have it we have an
organizer slack and we have these
discussions and really the truth is at
different regions of the world face
different problems you know it's
different in the Middle East and in
India and in Africa and even in southern
Europe versus sort of the challenges
that we face in the u.s. so as a as a
community organizer there are things
that work really well for us and then
there are things that don't work so well
so we've been working with O'Reilly
Media if you know O'Reilly they put on
the strata conferences they put on the
AI conference they put on us con okay
and so you know they're really great
recruiting women speaking having
diversity scholarships and Mel Kampf has
to come in into a 50-percent speakers be
women we have relationships where we
share information and they can recruit
speakers and I'm gonna skip over that
[Music]
hang on just a minute I'm going to I'm
just gonna skip over some stuff because
I want to make sure I cover the other
things we have a job board on our
website and so you're welcome to look if
you're looking for a job you can look on
the website if your company wants to
post a job you can post on the website
it's it's free it's really because we
have such a large community of over
40,000 members if you're hiring it's a
way to reach out to you know a whole
pipeline of students and current
professionals for work and these are our
social media pretty much women is
everywhere on social media is how you
can find us I I do want to talk just
about in general about diversity
initiatives and so one of them is
measuring inclusion there's not always
an easy way to measure inclusion we can
look at it in terms of how many women
are present at an event we're at a
company but it's it's really difficult
to quantify you know there are all these
women in tech organizations and
initiatives it's difficult to sort of
measure the impact you know exactly
which what is working and what is not
and the other thing that I would say is
you know after doing this for five years
I've really realized that you know we we
say women and X but really there's a lot
of other there's a lot of other
dimensions of diversity that are
important to consider and you are G
stands for underrepresented groups so
it's people in terms of sexual
orientation in terms of disability in
terms of just people being parents or
not parents age and you know like it's
important to consider all of those and
when they're all considered then all
those other groups will be supported the
other challenge I would say with
community is that they're all volunteer
run and so they can go dormant you know
when when when the one that when they
volunteer is something some have
something happens in their life where
they have to go on and do something else
they can go dormant I looked up to see
if there was a pie ladies an arbor and
they have a twitter handle the last time
they tweeted was May 2015 and I clicked
on the meetup group over there and sorry
the group you have doesn't exist anymore
and so one of the things that's happened
with pie ladies over the course of they
were founded in 2011 so that's eight
years at since their founding they've
opened up close to 200 chapters and I
would estimate that only 1/3 of them are
actually active now because you know
groups open and close and people people
go on with their life and so the
challenge is with that to keep community
groups active is having there's really
engaging with the organizers in the
community that keeps them active we do
that in will des but I can tell also
tell you that it takes a lot of time and
resources to do that because it requires
more volunteer support at that level and
so some of the options that I have for
that
to have somebody ask this question is to
have like a lot of active organizers so
when one or two leave or have a life
event happening that it can continue on
mentoring new organizers really it's
sort of like creating that pipeline of
people and something else is this gets
down to funding is really getting paid
staff to manage and provide global
support for these organizations at some
point a volunteer staff can only go so
far and managing burnout burnout is real
for volunteer organizing in any
community and I think it's important to
to manage that I'm gonna do a quick
spiel on partnership on AI it is a
consortium that was started by tech
giants and they have 90 partner members
including a lot of NGOs I bring it up
because women and machine learning data
science just became a partner
organization and so the goals for this
organization is they want to develop and
share best practices advance public
understanding they really want to move
AI development forward in a responsible
way
and this is when they announced our AI
and so what you can do really the key
thing about this is they have these
draft documents that are available and
the goal is to like provide information
on to companies and organizations and
they have one one on the visa policy
paper they have about ml which is best
practices for transparency machine
learning and they have other
subcommittees and these public Community
College
documents are available for review and
comments so you don't have to be a
partner organization you don't have to
be on a committee they go through their
cycles and these documents are available
so you can sign up for their newsletter
and also follow them on Twitter and I
will I have more slides but I think I
will end here I am on Twitter my name is
Rasmus OS is my last name initial I have
a website with a lot of vlogs available
and my email is available here and
I guess now I can take questions yeah
okay anybody have any questions yes I'll
repeat the question the question was
there are people who have the get skills
but they are not sure what project to
begin contributing to is that the
question okay
to that I would say use the one project
was something that they actually use in
their work so for instance if you're
doing data science machine learning
there is scikit-learn example but also
people use pandas numpy and all of these
other projects so something that people
use and starting off with really really
simple fixes and working working up to
more complex fixes that's that would be
my suggestion
yes
when her bitter they're like oh stop
citizen
yes so one thing that you could do is in
your work if you find problems like
sometimes you know you might run a
regression and friends tends let's just
say it's set up to do a binary problem
but you're you're submitting a
multi-class but they're not giving you
an informative error is to if you find a
situation like that you could you could
you could you could submit that fix you
could open the issue a lot of these
projects that I know scikit-learn does
that is they're labeled they're labeled
easy
they're also labeled easy first issue
and so and and if they're not you can
actually reach out to contributors and
ask and they're helpful that way
yes
it was one of them around open-sourcing
the open spring model that you
yes so the question was in my
presentation there was some links about
open sourcing the open source print
model yes so I'm putting together
documentation on how to organize an open
source print it's focused on when will
des but it doesn't really have to be a
will des it's you know it's available to
every organization and so I've started
I'm about 50% through my documentation
but I intend to finish it and I do want
to do it because a lot of people reach
out to me and ask questions and so it's
really having a one-hour conference call
with people is not the most efficient
use of my time so I do want to read out
their documentation so they have that
information available and then if there
are other questions then I can add to it
or you know speak to them yes it's
coming it is it is on my blog so
actually there's one that's half written
on it yeah I don't know if I can figure
out how to get to it but yeah I mean on
this I know how to get to it but now in
this machine but yeah that's the link to
my blog so it's actually the top post
right now but it's half written any
other questions yes
I'm popping up around the world I guess
it was curious to know how if you know
how they kind of learn about this and
what kind of their motivations are for
reaching out and starting a chapter and
then kind of what the ongoing
relationship looks like these chapters
okay so I'll repeat the question the
question was for women in machine
learning data science we have close to
80 chapters how are people finding out
about women machine learning data
science they're finding out through I
would say two main things
twitter is big twitter is very popular
we have close to 12,000 followers the
other one which is the same podcast that
Shawn and I were on after I was on the
podcast data framed which I don't know
doesn't anyone listen state data framed
okay so after that podcast at the end of
that podcast I had a call to action and
I talked about women issue in their data
science you know I said if you want to
open a new chapter I think we just
received like emails after emails from
people all over the world like Gaborone
a New South Wales Australia all over
Africa Middle East India - and that's I
would say Twitter and that podcast are
the two main avenues yeah yes yes so we
have a slack channel for the organizers
and people ask questions you know about
organizing events we've put together a
lot of resources for them so we have
there's an introductory slide
presentation there's a starter kit on
how to get started when will des will
create the Meetup
so we asked them just make sure they
read our terms and agreements and agree
to our code of conduct and then we open
up the meetup chapter for them to cover
their dues and they if they have any
questions about specific events they ask
on slack so we are a very very lucky
interactive community I mentioned before
that that engagement is very important
supporting the organizers and being in
touch with them
you show the data right beginning so he
said woman's yes factor let's factor
what is the reasoning behind right so I
don't know if you're eager deeper into
that what happened right to them so that
they show visible first present one
question yeah I see so the question was
what is the reason for the low rates of
women in tech compared to in the medical
profession and the legal profession
there's a lot of discussion out there
there's a lot of strong feelings about
it there's a lot of discussion about the
culture in tech there is I mean people
talk about the culture in tech I would
say and also the pipeline of the
different fields where people are
getting involved in terms of computer
science computer science is a major
field and yet the number of female
students in computer science is really
really low compared to like all these
other fields whether it's biology
whether it's statistics and all of that
and so that entire so that entire
ecosystem has an impact on how many
women are down the line are in tech and
also the problem with tech is even for
women that are in tech women leave Tech
at a higher rate than any other field so
there's like there's a leak also but the
discussion is culture yes
so you mentioned earlier about funding
especially sponsorship for four events
what is the best way for knowing our
audience but are people viewing this at
home too what is the best way for them
to contribute funds or to reach out
maybe it directly to you so there's a
couple of ways if you want to support
scikit-learn they are an affiliated
project of non focus that you can
generator Lucretia if there's a specific
sprint in a region that you want a
sponsor you can reach out to info at
whim LDS o RG and there is windmill GS
has a website wim LDS o RG that has a
page also for donating well hopefully
this has given us a lot of food for
thought and let's think reach them again
for great talk